that can help reduce ADHD symptoms.
now, there has been an interesting study that I found
a while back,
back in 2010,
where they took not only people who took 5HDP,
but did a combination
where they knew people with ADHD issues
not only have low levels of serotonin
but also have low levels of dopamine and norepinephrine.
because this is a common issue with people with ADHD
having both low levels of serotonin and dopamine
and norepinephrine.
you can't just take something like 5HGP.
5HGP, like we just discussed before
does help improve levels of serotonin
now, they've also seen in some research
by just taking 5 HTP alone
can also sometimes reduce also dopamine.
so what they did in this study is
they took children between the ages of 8 and 18,
about 85 participants.
and what they did is they had them take a combination
of 5 HTTP and also L tyrosine.
these are important types of amino acids
that help improve serotonin and also dopamine.
that way. one is not being ignored.